hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my flash episode 10 video full-on
vibe versus gypsies such as careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet we got to talk about Wally and Barry
versus savat our first 19 teasers for
the flash of that earth there's so much
stuff but there is a new round of the
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment about the episode on this video
be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts so that you don't miss anything
so let's do top 10 in comic book Easter
eggs number 10 the intro to the electric
gang with Harrison wells narrating his
novel I love that he keeps trying to
sell people on this even when [ __ ] had
a blader in the episode during the trial
by combat he was trying to sell her on
it while they were waiting for the
battle to start the big thing with him
in this episode is all about doing
something that matters that was kind of
the theme across the entire episode for
all the characters making sure that
their life had meaning and that's why a
chart came to this earth so number 9
that led [ __ ] to come after him as a
collector so we get all this lore and
backstory on earth 19th hopefully we'll
get to see it really soon because she
let us know that she's not surprised by
speedsters she's able to cut them off
from the Speed Force using her vibe
powers so that means that Cisco can do
it too but because he's not as good he
hasn't learned about all those things
yet the reason she explains did she came
for HR is because he broke their most
sacred law interdimensional travel
because 25 years ago in their history
another earth invaded theirs and they
set up this travel ban she's part of a
task force that tracks those people down
that break the law and it's basically a
death sentence and now she has to say
that he's dead so he can never go home
but number 8 you can kind of see what
they're setting up for hrs character so
they have that Lego set of irises death
and they know that they CH are in the
future on the rooftop with that gun so
they're like do we send them back do we
stop him from going back we know that HR
is destined to show up like Cisco said
at the end of the episode so what I
think that they might be doing is
setting us up to really care for HR
because he's kind of a douchebag
you're definitely made to hate him when
he first shows up he's so annoying so
at the end of the season I think the
idea is to make you love him for him to
do something that gives his life meaning
and then they'll join the rug right out
from under us kill him in a battle with
Sava tar or someone else and that'll
give Tom Cavanagh reason to play another
character in season 4 I just don't think
that HR is going to be here next season
so there has to be a reason for him to
go away
and he can't go back to earth 19 now so
right now he's at the top of the list of
people who might die at the end of the
season because I think we can all agree
that iris is probably not going to die
they'll find a way to save her and it
has to do with Wally number seven Barry
and Wally teaming up and showing off new
flash powers to take down the Electric
gang at the beginning of the episode so
they sort of like vibrate around each
other so the guns can't get a lock on
them take them down they'll be doing
more of that because they tease that
Barry's going to be training him at the
end of the episode to get faster and
faster the whole idea is that he's
getting way faster in a much faster rate
so that he'll be fast enough to help
Barry say virus from Savitt are because
so far Barry's been thinking about this
in a very singular way I have to be fast
enough to save iris but now we have two
flashes and that doesn't even include
Jay Garrick or Jessie quick or any of
the other speedsters of the multiverse
they already had the speech in the
episode where he talked to Cisco about
getting through the tough times he says
I lean on you guys you guys keep me
going in the dark time so he's just
learning to rely on the rest of team
flesh now he's going to rely on Wally to
help him out with his sabot our problem
in really nice Smallville easter-egg you
guys may have noticed the cheerleaders
that Wally rescued that he was taking
all the selfies with look exactly like
the cheerleaders from Smallville so
there's a whole bunch of Wally stuff
that they're building out in the back
half of the season there's rumors that
he might guest star on legends of
tomorrow but what I'm really hoping is
is they tease some of the powers that
Wally develops that Barry does not have
every member of the flash family learns
to use the Speed Force in slightly
different ways so they have slightly
different abilities one of the big ones
he develops in the comics is sort of
like Superman's sunburst ability there's
a giant bursts of electrical speed force
energy so number six the other big thing
here too that I love
is a julienne is on the team he's like
this cold mathematician who's like to
get [ __ ] done person so like they're
trying to figure this plan out and he's
like look let's lose mathematics you
need to get this fast by this time or
else you're not going to be able to save
her he's the one that had the idea to
create the Lego set he's also striving
for meaning there's so much left for his
character this season I feel like he's
still tied to the philosopher's stone
there has to be a reason force avatar to
come back to our earth so there's a
number of ways that could go down I have
a feeling it'll have something to do
with dr. alchemy so right now Julia is
just doing what everyone else is trying
to do make his life half meaning learn
to be on the team but he's one of the
new guys so he just sort of pipes up
it's a really awkward moments really
funny responses like oh well she must
have been having an off day otherwise
Cisco would have totally died number 5
is iris distracting Joe by teasing the
tornado twins in the comics she and
Barry have two children they're twins
they themselves have speed powers but
their son dawn allen has a son named
Bart Allen so he's the one that comes
back from the future to fight with team
flash during the Mark Waid era of the
comics that's when Wally West was the
main version of the flash but she takes
it right back in an instant says do you
think the Barry is a dog person or a cat
person so it was just like a really
brief tease that they might have
children in the future so who knows if
we'll ever do that on the TV show I'm
assuming not because if we do see their
children if we did see Bart Allen on the
show it would probably be in a flash
forward or like in the comics Bart would
show up from the future in present day
and they would really know where he came
from till he explained himself but I
totally loved iris and Wally teaming up
brother-sister crime-fighting team just
like during flashpoint hopefully they'll
do that again during the season they
have a nice energy together so there
seems were a lot of fun but that whole
iris storyline was really just to set up
that payoff at the end where she's
telling Barry how she's worried that
she's going to be like her mother she'll
just go away and she won't have left any
kind of mark so Barry has to calm her
down so it was a great payoff it was a
great moment but you know most of those
Irish scenes felt a little out of pace
with the Cisco versus gypsies storylines
but it's all about doing something
meaningful with your life so there's
somatic consistency across the episode
number four with Cisco's cow
two gypsy trial by combat very timely
Game of Thrones reference mixed with The
Lord of the Rings reference come and
claim him so he was just throwing them
left and right in the funny thing is is
that he learns that gypsy also has her
own references to a spinal tap that's
nice as she's sucking him through the
portal to the other earth but the
training montage was great the whole
energy with all the characters was so
much better in this episode Sisko wasn't
all mopey Julianne was funny he had
really nice comedic timing with Caitlin
we'll work on your interpersonal skills
so the energy in the group is so much
better in the back half of the season
I'm so much happier with what's going on
now number three was vibe versus gypsy
multiverse battle so there were three
different earths that they went to
you
thank you for the reader distract me
because you're afraid the first one they
went to was earth to Sisko recognizes
that he's like holy crap this is earth
to that kind of tease up that we're
going to be seeing earth to again really
quickly with the gorilla City episode
that's two parts so we'll see just a
quick again real soon the next earth
they go to is supergirls earth earth 38
there in cat Grant's office you see miss
Tessmacher like oh my god somebody calls
Supergirl
she must be off helping somebody else in
this last planet looks like something
right out of Star Wars like it's mu
stefarr anakin versus obi-wan next to
the lava and I almost completely forgot
to mention we got to talk about Sisko in
the full vibe costume for the first time
in present-day and he refers to himself
as vibe for the very first time you can
call me vibe or Cisco or anything else
gypsy was just so much fun in this
episode so hands down gypsy is one of my
favorite new characters you can
definitely expect her to come back
sometime maybe even before the end of
the season just in the way that they
left things number two is actually the
mystery speedster from Earth 19 the
Chiti is like oh you're a speedster like
she's totally seen a bunch before that's
the accelerated man that everybody's
been asking about for the past couple of
months so I think the idea is that we'll
see him sometime in the next couple of
weeks who won't have to wait too long
but the flash is going on break after
next week's episode
so like the two-part gorilla City
episode won't be for three weeks instead
of just two weeks so it's going to be a
while but we'll see him pretty soon he
actually came from the most diversity
Grant Morrison comic so he doesn't have
like a really big backstory so the TV
show is free to do whatever they want to
with him but a lot of people are
wondering if it might be Eddie Thawne
because he just showed up behind the
scenes but the episode they're filming
with him is like episode 18 so it's not
anywhere near the gorilla city episode
so whatever Eddie is doing he's probably
not going to be the accelerated man
although it would be cool for him to be
a speedster in a future season but the
number one thing of course is very
teasing that Wally is the key to
defeating Favot are there's a number of
different ways they could take this
because comic book ginger Wally in the
comics eventually became the fastest
version
of the flesh he even has white lightning
in the rebirth comics right now likes
avatar has so they could take it that
direction but because Barry is always
here in this moment I feel like it'll be
a two on one thing where he distracts
avatar and Wally runs in to save iris as
opposed to Barry running up and
snatching her out of his claws because
the problem with making Wally faster
than sabotage is that the show would be
over if Wally became that powerful
if Barry became that powerful then there
be nobody to challenge them there'd be
no drama anymore so whatever the
solution to defeating savat are is this
season there's still a couple ways to
defeat him it won't leave them being
all-powerful so even though eventually
Barry will probably join the Speed Force
become the god of speed himself that's
in like the distant future of the show
but you can let me know in the comments
how do you think that Barry is going to
use Wally to help save iris I feel like
it's going to be you know him
distracting savitur while Rolly runs in
to snatch rock but there's still a
number of ways they could do that so
like I said there's a new episode next
week the week after that the flash goes
on break so I'll just remind people as I
post new bonus videos what's going to
happen next is is I'll post a trailer
video for next week's episode then I'll
post legends of tomorrow Legion of do so
much reverse flashback story that they
told and make sure you watch arrow to
because that video will post Wednesday
night they're introducing a new version
of The Black Canary
so they'll explain how that's going to
work so it's a really important episode
I will say congratulations to Devin
McBrain you're the new flash ring
giveaway winner there's a new round that
started in this video I'll remind
everyone when I post my trailer video in
the morning where you guys wait for that
to post you can click here to learn all
about the Flash's greatest power and you
can click here sport all about what's
going on with the Batman movie thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you in the next video
you